all right so each hole is worth points
it's one point two point three points
four points then you got that
checkerboard money ball to go anywhere
okay so you go that's a one point is the
start of something all right
it was Josh Norman here we go
that's absolutely one pointer okay now
two pointer here we go in the counter a
corner Josh Norman
he now has three points suck it you get
this you get this you get this you beat
Michael Irvin on the game just to get a
little bit competitive courses going
there you go Josh Norman for a three
pointer he already has three to double
his total here we go Josh Norman for the
lead the Rich Eisen show lead he's
already beaten Irvin and Ryan Leaf this
is for the outright lead the four
pointer Josh Norman oh that's really
hard the Moneyball you can go anywhere
you want you can go where two points one
point the three would give you the lead
right here if you want to go for the
three okay or you can go for the four
you go here we go here I'll take this
down alright Josh Norman Washington
Redskins for the outright lead here we
go
michael irvin we sat here you are only
five points Josh Norman leaped over the
leaderboard like it was a bull in
Pamplona and he's now leading after
jarring a Moneyball putt for just three
points you use strategy used to stroke
Josh Norman I very rarely start with
this on a chauffeur guess
congratulations for being on the Rich
Eisen show thanks Rachel thanks for
having me I appreciate how often do you
do you golf Josh but hearing you though
break that down it's amazing well yeah I
was doing my my golf voice I mean Reggie
Bush he it seemed like a scratch golfer
Chris I mean he like he's history he
came in he came in here and came in here
was very much drag we showed pictures of
Tiger Woods giving him lessons yeah you
just beat him Josh it's impressive I
mean I guess when the lights come on who
comes out it's good to see you think and
it's great to see you in one piece so
let me start with this I will ask the
question that many football fans many
just human beings in America last week
was asking when video of you from
Pamplona in Spain came back just uh real
basic question what the hell were you
thinking
you know just tackle a challenge to most
wouldn't do I would say so what why
why'd you do it
I just trying up a new booster package
and I was working on this year me I'm
and every year you gotta help evolve
yourself into something else and this
year we went a little bit above that
you know we world class but no I for me
though is is literally like I mean would
you rather you know live and die mmm
would you rather die and never lived for
me and you can do anything pretty much
that sums it up as you can do anything
in this world or anything in this life
you can just go outside your front door
and get in the car and something
happened to you accident happens you
were safe you can even go out there and
be in practice and be on the football
field and Terra ACL and you're safe I
can go out there and the pools and not
do something exciting and something that
you know brings out the best in me in my
life in my world mm-hmm and I win it
then I become victorious at that this
issue I said it because it's something
that I feel like I'm doing that it's
like bringing peace and bringing joy to
me and I'm excited outweigh the risk of
course I've never had done if I didn't
you know this is for me though is that
thrill and that excitement that I get
and then you look on the people's faces
and they in a celebratory moment yeah
can't that repeat that man well you know
I saw it and my first thought was okay
I'm assuming he prepared for this did
you know for sure okay well you go
through I didn't really prepare because
we're not winning arena like I feel like
somebody else took control of me and I
became like and I'm modern-day kind of
like gladiator you know being in there
back in that time and just feeling it
you know this the Coliseum with the
sands and the people that was around and
you've seen it everything and then pull
out and you see the everybody running
and you know King some people getting
just smashed by the bull right and then
you look at it and I'm like okay
everybody go and run it up in encircling
and going to touch it again his way just
take it up a notch and just jump over
over so we just looked the video and I
don't think the bull moves very much you
did in fact leap over the the length the
height and length of the bowl yeah uh
you know
[ __ ] up I had to size it up um pretty
much have calculations to the point
where you never wanted to jump behind it
because you never know what it may do
may turn right left on a dime so I want
it just to face it head-on the bull did
just put its head down did did you think
it was about to try and Gore you when
you it was Francoeur you know I mean
literally it came straight not wrinkly
so I charge back at it like hey who's
gonna win big fella
and so I decided to go over and I knew I
was gonna clear it was just something
that you know I just made sure when I
got down that it was a pretty clean man
and I could do those 746 just John low
Josh Norman here on the Rich Eisen show
have you heard from the Redskins have a
yeah what'd they say nothing really say
something I don't know I sitting
I just don't know yeah I mean your
school I mean you're a very integral
member of the team yeah you know so if
I'm a management or a coach and I'm like
seeing this video somebody's presenting
it to me I'm like what's he doing okay
[Laughter]
personnel I think you personnel know who
you know right who's the person that
you're talking with and knowing that
that person in loves that type of stuff
and knowing that he won't put himself in
jeopardy enough to put the team in
jeopardy because for me I just feel like
something like that it's nothing to me
when you look at it and all I've half
done and and just completely took myself
in a role that most can't do that I mean
some guy got gored here in his neck I
think it was like a lawyer something
from here got gored and thinking I'm
like well you gotta know your personnel
you go out there around the bull get the
horns you don't you know athletic enough
move out the way because the video we've
seen here it's in an arena did you
literally run the streets with them -
yeah I did one using what is that like
oh my gosh it's crazy
yes by far the most craziest scariest
funnest thing I've ever done just
because you know you got those 1505
Bulls just running the streets like six
of them you hear those bales and then
you see all the people
coming and a are running fast but it's
not though boys I want to make this
clear it's not the Bulls that get you
what is it
it's the people it's literally the
people because the people will not move
out of your way and then we run in some
fool looking back and then they end up
jumping and pumping into you and then
there you go out on the streets and
those Bulls charging the insulin now for
nobody especially hit a dead man's curve
they in that Bank
and if you know if you in that bank and
he trapped between a wall and them it's
over with Mike's out and is there I'm
being serious is there anything similar
to running a ball back running a pic
back in the NFL to that sort of thing I
mean obviously there's no life or death
issue but when you like when there's
people all over the place you guys -
running through traffic or being in a
situation like that is there any
comparison to the rush or the sensory
perception of it well you still get that
adrenaline you still get that adrenaline
rush for sure it's pretty much like I
don't know if I want to say this but you
watch the waterboy Bobby Boucher I call
that point number 27 he ran through
those holes those Tuesday and it was
like just him right and then the end
zone and then you just saw that
everybody was celebrating right in that
moment it's kind of like that feel it's
kind of like that but you have that just
I don't know that excitement just comes
through you but then that rush like oh
shoot I got these Bulls behind me if I
don't get away ain't getting moving
right now through those tools then
something's gonna happen and I'm not
trying to be a part of that person that
happened into it so for me I looked at
it as I'm a sprint as fast as I can get
out of Dodge and see what happens and
some idiot came out the left side of me
and just wiped me out there Bank it real
quick and so I saw somebody follow the
top of me and then the Bulls was coming
and I was like Louis make sure he stays
on top of me so the bull come here be
him before me
this is what was going through this
happened oh yeah but it's like literally
I I was on the left side but the thing
is the booze went straight down the
middle day I'll never veer off okay um
it's not nothing that they don't get
trapped one get behind they catch up to
the rest of the herd and so when I got
up I started running to the rest of the
on crew I had the UM the pack bulls
there's like four of them running behind
me so I was running in front of them all
the way into the arena and once I got in
that arena everybody was like
celebrating having a good time and then
the next thing I know they end up then
the bull out I've never seen his coming
and they let him out and everybody start
running around and I was like holy Sh
she's like these guys coming out running
and so I saw that and I try to take it
up a notch and so when I jump to the
first time everybody started like cheer
- yelling I was like okay that's pretty
cool
and then I did it the second time and
that hurt is worth else out to the
little stopped at all and I don't know
what that means I left one day and then
I started hearing that through the
streets and I was like okay whatever and
came back the second day did it again
and they stopped the music and
everything they just start yelling it in
the stance to you to me like me now I'm
a football player here in the States
you're correct yes sir they don't know
me from Adam house Lona
get bear yeah and they starts chanting
that name so I'm like a hero in Spain
almost not even back here let me so hold
on Ana's let me get this I can use this
on any host of shows this NFL season
else at the door yes just like the
jumper the jumper so I would love just
one second in my life to have the words
l sachet or chanted to me it was like
the most exhilarating feeling every that
I just it came upon me just hearing that
and used
you know it's like you back in that
gladiator space of Tom you know nice
there what's been going since like 15
the 1590s and now here is a 2019 Josh
Norman on the Rich Eisen show I I asked
this with no hint of sarcasm or irony is
this something that you think you can
use this fall like literally you've you
jumped over a bull you you did this so
now what you do for a living in the NFL
one on one on an island or trying to
stop somebody come in like a bowl at you
one on one is this something you can use
well I'll say this is there's no fear
factor that's in me then I won't do well
III wouldn't have thought the word fear
factor for you was even in the realm
Josh I'm not gonna like I know you know
Josh Norman so what's the one adjectives
you use I mean fearful would not have
been the word though but is there
something like now that you're okay so
it's just another thing that you don't
just scratch that off the list pretty
much I mean look death in the eye and I
cheated it literally over top of it but
Adam I could I'm pretty sure I will
well here's one one I'll give you one
week where it's gonna work tell me week
nine do you know what you're playing in
week nine
you want to take one it's at the bills
at the Buffalo Bills so take your pick
at any one of those bills just leap
right over them so is this just it's
interesting you're playing you're
playing the bills you know when it's all
happening I know right you don't play
you don't play Cleveland do you do I
play Cleveland I think we'd add them in
preseason we got them in okay yeah what
do you think of Adele's new digs what do
you think of that I don't know man I
think he um digs a woman what he's new
spot Cleveland spot yeah because
everybody there's all sorts of buzz
around the Cleveland Browns it is
there's a lot of buzz I got a lot of
people there a lot of talent that's for
sure um it's just if they got those guys
can all work together
and find a way to get it done because
got a lot of personalities in that team
a lot of them so if they all mesh will I
don't see why they can't be a playoff
contending team well I'm not saying that
this would happen with Cleveland but
walk me through how how would too many
personalities on a team affect a team
put on put your analyst hat on that you
do from time to time I don't want to say
I don't I'll take that back and say
personalities I just think everybody on
the same page because you can have a lot
of personalities and everybody can you
know mesh well with that as well but if
you have those personalities and they
don't mesh with each other then that
creates a type of chaos that you don't
want and it could come out on the field
and come out on a feeling it difficult I
love it too in the locker room and
that's the thing that you don't want so
I don't I want I want to say you're
gonna have no no no it they have that
you know type of talent that can be
great if they allow it to like grow in
over time you know that is you know
watered and taken care of and it grows
and sprout up to something great okay
now I know when you were on last we were
talking about Haskins you seen him first
blush yes it looks like he's your guy
here and eek fella what do you like a
big yeah he's really got big arm you
know it's leaked so a lot of things it's
not gonna come as easy as it it was for
him because there's some stuff he has to
learn terminology and then you know
throws some throws that he make he don't
make here because the tighter windows is
so much more tired of windows and he's
seeing it and his confidence you don't
ever want to bust that up but you want
to show him and help him to get better
each and every day with all he's doing
and but he has all the tangibles to be a
really great quarterback this is gonna
be exciting it's gonna be him I can't
leave it no seriously I mean you know
today Kyler Murray shows up for work
today yeah Duane Haskins gonna get the
start obviously for you guys it seems
like I'd want to know
I mean he's he you know he's he's a
hometown kid Alex Smith just had a brace
removed it's
obviously he's it's not like he's gonna
be coming back anytime soon and that's
terrible and unfortunate I'm just I'm
excited for all of these storylines in
the NFL just rookies alone and ones
right there for you yeah and you know
having a rookie quarterback can be
maddening sometimes but also in this day
and age it seems that these kids are
coming out of college ready to go more
often than not these days you know yeah
I think the league has done a good job
with that transition for you know the
rookies quarterbacks just because of how
they set them up and how what we can't
do anymore as a defender towards that
and we'll allow that to you know be a
little bit more open to where they can
succeed more some guys take that medal
and they step up to it and some it takes
them years to develop because you got to
think about it they are babies infants
coming into this to be a great
quarterback you don't start get done not
until you in your fifth year you just
really start to get going you know what
I'm saying some guys you know cut that
in half but it's it's what you make it
because I see those guys at quarterback
position as being the UM the premium for
what we do well yeah they certainly paid
like it - yeah they are
[Laughter]
um they they do a good job man it's a
hard position to play it really is but
then you look around they have to they
have to carry a lot on those shoulders
especially when you got guys like me
looking down and staring down that
barrel ready to take a take a bite out
of crime anytime I can get it like that
like McGruff the Crime Dog right that I
believe is so um and then the last time
we spoke as well it was not yet totally
official yeah that dpi and offensive
pass interference would be reviewable
this year so so how does that make your
life any tougher do you think oh we play
with the game now you play with the game
something that's been going on I don't
know I mean almost yeah what this is the
season so
it's been still the same game it still
the same game 11 guys on each side going
out ready and trying to win the ballgame
but now we're from the analytic
analytics to it and we're starting to
you know how would I say baby
the Watchers that's watching it into
something that they feel as if they want
to make this game perfect when it's an
imperfect game playing by imperfect
people like how do you do that how do
you make something right then you gonna
have to go back and watch everything you
got to replay this you don't have to
replate it for soon we're gonna start
getting flags every flag gonna probably
have to replay it now because you open
that up when you do that I mean we play
on the outside as we try to go and get
the football okay you may have a tuck
here and there you may have a push off
here and there but to sit back and then
two minutes of the game when you get it
all the way down to that you fall all
the way in those four quarters and you
get down to the end of it and you can
call a flag on a play and go back and
replay it and see if the DB tugs or not
and see if it offers a pass interference
came like we got into that part we came
from alway and the beginning to two now
we go to looking at the replay to
determine the game and giving the ball
to someone else and then they set up for
a field goal and you walk off the field
because of that play that one person is
probably gonna have his head down for
the rest of the year if the season is
over with and you'd pin it on that play
how would you feel any differently if
you were a saint what I have to last
after the lis NFC championship course
I'll be pissed but it is what it is I
mean I would literally be pissed but
what can you do I mean that's the game
what explanation they're gonna give you
it's over with can't go back and replay
it can't go back and do anything you
just be better for it and they sure and
literally don't put it in the hands of
the officials that would he always say
play better than the refs right you have
to like because you know you playing
against two teams you playing against
damn in the press but at the same time
like you have to pretty much put on your
pants and get the game over with quick
so you don't have to put in that
because if you do the outcome will not
be in your favor if you think it will
yeah cuz the the number of challenges
that a coach can use has not been
expanded so during the game there won't
be you know more and the coach is gonna
really have to think about it because
when you open up replay anything that's
reviewable can be reviewed so offensive
pass interference can be seen if you're
if they're trying to check to see if you
had a defensive pass interference call
yeah and they see a receiver shove off
you they could say no Josh Norman was
good it's the receiver that was the
issues flag for offensive pass
interference so a coach's gonna have to
think twice about it it is the last two
minutes of the game where this is going
to be a potential I'm saying I mean me
I'm just gonna chalk it up to the game
it is what it is like I'm playing hole
four quarters and I get down to two
minutes in that happens like whatever
man like really whatever
because I've been god they're playing
bust my tail and bust my chops freakin
60 58 minutes it comes out of two
minutes what you want to call a a pass
interference by something I've done and
I end up making the play on like
whatever I head up to the game seriously
because I can't do anything outside of
that space and try to defend these you
know guys who's you know our fastest
head fast as lightning you know they can
turn a split second of a dime
quarterback knows where he's going with
the ball receiver nose around he's
running and I'm trying to defend that
backpedaling like get out of here man
literally like this is the support we
play so we know we get into it like I've
been playing for all my life and sit
down there on the edge like literally
I'm gonna defend what is mine and I'm
gonna do it to the best of my abilities
and the refs know that about me and
they're my buddies like literally I like
I talked to them before the game and
after the game and they understand how
we get down so if anything comes up
they'll let me know and I'll watch it
but before it in I'm in it before I let
you go what you're wearing as stars 24
shares what is this about Josh I'm a
nonprofit organization that we found it
back in 2012 and actually I started
myself in the league and we've been
going every single year and helping out
the kids in my hometown and other areas
lonna in Carolina home in my hometown
Greenville South Carolina and then other
places which in Charlotte on Washington
DC and Florida and just other places we
go around and we try to help and touch
others and kids and and we do a lot of
things on Eddie and even with McAllen
Texas was out there and we was over in
Flint and doing some things there as
well and so we coming up with a center
that will
we're opening Team Center where we
teamed up with Boys and Girls Club of
America that will be groundbreaking come
Monday the 22nd so Raby ribbon-cutting
so it's gonna be a week for you you get
a ribbon cutting and a groundbreaking
and then opening of training camp for
your eighth season yeah the 24th man is
right around the corner it seems so fast
what's your number right it is I'm a dot
connector that's what I do
you cover people you jump over bulls you
live your life you finished with second
and dance with the Stars which was
awesome to see and yes move the dots and
I connect the dots and now you're our
leader board leader so I'll take that
one but I'll say this though say this
yes if you do connect the dots tell me
how you miss the dots with those
pictures back there well we're gonna
connect that dot again you were 2,000
year old okay we've started we've
started just in the past year and a half
all right that's a lot what we're gonna
bout to take a picture okay and that
photographs going on the wall I thought
was better than that we are we are
better than that judge snow up there
he's just starting not too long ago like
he just had him on the show we are ease
up there we definitely on the show first
that is true it's true that's true okay
so we're about to take a photo and it's
going to go on the wall I mean you know
you were one of my favorites Josh Norman
at a Jay underscore no 24 and no
underscore on Instagram that's Twitter
and Instagram go follow that to learn
more about stars with a Z 24 Josh
Norman's program good to see you man oh
good let's chat throughout the season as
you matriculate your way you only face
the entire NFC East three of the first
four weeks right out of the gate and
then you got a Chicago home date on
Monday Night Football
that's your September sir I know right
it is fast it's coming it is I know and
July is almost over that's Josh Norman
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app